aujourd'hui nous vivons une tragédie
nationale
don porte à croire ce serait une attaque
terroriste deuxième tour de ligne
se sont écrasés
world trade center ça t'arrive à toi des
fois de ne pas pouvoir sortir de transit
le matin et barbra c'est mon cas
aujourd'hui
rien à signaler
jaffray qu'est ce qu'il ya j'en sais
rien du tout est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
tombait bien honda trente deux
ascenseurs hors service pour le réseau
entre les étages supérieurs
métissé dit jamais
obama oui tu on est encore dans le world
trade
vous pouvez lui dire d'appeler ma femme
j'aime bien là aussi pas mal écrit
ayew
c
je crois qu'on a été attaqué l'explosion
est de sentir problème la tour sud
[Musique]
je vous appelle de la part de votre mari
et voulez vous c'est chic
vous devez quitter le bâtiment
immédiatement mais c'est moi non mariés
[Musique]